alright guys bang bang I've got Tom down
here I'm super excited to to cover this
and hopefully I'm gonna learn some
alongside everyone else today so thanks
so much for doing this yeah thanks so
much for having me pop excited to be
here for sure let's uh let's start with
your background you've done a bunch of
cool [ __ ] in in the tech world kind of
walk us through how we get to you being
encrypted yeah sure so my first job out
of school was as an associate product
manager at Google I had basically come
out of an internship at Microsoft and
wanted to do literally anything other
than go back had a great time there
working on search and Android spent some
time at Google X working on project loon
launching stratospheric balloons and
working on Internet connectivity and
rural parts of the world and then
basically caught the crypto bug went
down the rabbit hole and have been a
co-founder and been working on coined
tracker cryptocurrency tax and portfolio
solution since then okay so we got to
talk about Google the two things that
I'm really interested on is the APM
program the associate project manager
described a little bit about just like
what that process was like and kind of
what you took away after having gone
through it I think it's probably one of
the more highly sought after programs
the large tech companies in Silicon
Valley is a great program the idea is
basically I think it was Marissa Mayer's
bet back in the early days that you
could basically take new grads and mold
them into product managers versus trying
to take people who had let's say lots of
business experienced or what kind of it
come from the traditional business world
and so it ended up being a cohort of
about thirty of us who are either recent
grads or new grads or people who had
recently come out of graduate school
some really smart colleagues of mine and
kind of a whirlwind tour stumping you
into a project whether that be search or
Android or YouTube or Chrome whatever
part of Google and basically having all
the responsibilities that you would have
a product manager so that could reign
from range from working on design
related
to doing queries and back you know back
office kind of analytics type of stuff
to working with engineering teams
privacy marketing so I ended working on
knowledge graph which is kind of the
tool that basically powers the results
on Google search when you search for a
question that has kind of an explicit
answer like how tall is Barack Obama or
more recently relevant is like Ovid
stats and you'll see a box with a bunch
of informations I kind of worked on the
team that would power those kinds of
structured language queries and then I
also worked on Google now which was like
a third party assistant type of
precursor products to help people figure
out relevant information about them at
the time that it was relevant so really
really cool experience lots of really
smart people in the program yeah and I
guess as you go through that program is
it something where they give you a lot
of leeway and they kind of say hey go
pick a team that you want to work on or
is it more of hey we think you're gonna
be great on you know X or Y team and
we're gonna place you in that it's a bit
of a magic black box so the first year
it's a bit more of they choose and they
put you on something and in the second
year you get to basically go this an
interview matching process where you can
talk to different managers and pick the
team or the area that you're most
excited about yeah when I was at a
Facebook every product manager that
joins for the most part doesn't know
what team they're gonna work on which
people always find really weird and it
sounds like that second year of the
interview match process where you go
interview all the managers and all that
managers are simultaneously interviewing
you and then you kind of pick and you
gotta have like a double opt-in come to
join the team right yeah it's like a
residency match for sure and so then
let's talk a little bit about Google X
and Project loon maybe just start with
what Google X is for those they don't
know basically I think that yeah
rebranded as X it's like this what
self-described moonshot Factory some of
the larger bets that alphabet largely
wants to take on kind of these pretty
crazy out there wild ideas that could
potentially turn into big businesses so
they have a framework about how they
think about this it's kind of
technological solutions applied to
really really big problems and kind of
these crazy scale
always so some examples of projects that
have come out of there are way mo the
self-driving car project I believe
Google brain started there at one point
loon is another big one and there's some
other examples too got and Project loon
is the whole idea using balloons to
basically beam the internet down an
increase internet coverage correct
that's exactly right especially focused
on at least at the time when I was
working on it a few years ago rural
areas where it's often not economical or
difficult to reach really far out
coverage because the cellphone towers
don't have enough range or you need a
Billy expensive backhaul to get into the
middle of Amazon you know jungle or
things like that got it and I guess as
part of this like what are the steps
everyone sitting around like hey I
wonder if we could beam the Internet
down I'm assuming that it looks like
each major tech companies taking
different paths right when I was at
Facebook they were looking at all sorts
of like essentially drones that could
fly for really long periods of time with
low energy consumption and go ahead and
beat me down Project loon wanted to use
balloons like what is that kind of just
the platform decision look like the tree
needs a wild and wacky process and
people are taking all different kinds of
approaches from satellites to drones I
think akela did that and then loon has
this kind of unconventional balloon
approach it's kind of a launch and
iterate type of thing you know you try a
bunch of different things you see what
works you see what doesn't work you see
what's gonna be economically feasible or
not there's lots of different pros and
cons to each platform satellites are
really really expensive balloons are
relatively speaking much cheaper but
with a satellite you know you put it in
orbit you kind of reliably or at least
some you reliably know where it's gonna
be balloons you have at the whims of the
wind so you kind of try these different
platforms see what the pros and cons are
you see how feasible they are and then
yeah you take the ones that are the most
promising I think having a local launch
an iterate approach is valuable year
because you don't want to lock yourself
into one solution early on that may not
end up working versus trying to actually
have a problem or a pain point you're
trying to solve in this case making
Internet connectivity better and then
iterating on the solution that works the
best you
and did you work on all this from
California or did you actually go out to
some of the locations where they were
testing it I was one of the lucky ones
who actually got to go out so I spent I
think over 45 days in Peru both in Lima
but also in some really rural places
that were super cool and awesome I went
to to Kenya so yeah I've got some field
experience too and they also have a
launch site for these balloons both in
the middle of the Nevada desert and
another one in Puerto Rico so yeah just
a lot of cool field stuff yeah and I
guess when you're there you're about to
launch the balloon like how does that
work I'm just fascinated by the fact of
like alright we're gonna take this
balloon it's really big and we're gonna
put it in the air and then just let it
float around and beam the Internet what
is that launch process look like so in
the early days it was literally just you
know a couple guys in a truck drive out
to the middle of nowhere Mojave Desert
and you know how to make ship like kind
of in your building in your garage type
of balloon but now they've gone to the
point where they're getting ready for
production rollouts and things like that
so there's actually a huge basically
construction crew of people that are
experts in their field that have built a
launch crane that is enormous it's like
six stories or taller and it
automatically like throws up the balloon
gets you know the necessary helium puts
it in the balloon fills it up launches
it automatically it's a pretty
autonomous process it's pretty amazing
to watch that happen and there's some
videos you can you can google them and
then there's basically an ex-military
crew of ops people who are like
responsible for all the logistics of
getting that up in the air and making
sure the launch is happening on time and
there's an air traffic control team
flight ops that basically 24/7 365 is
talking to flight controllers around the
world during Christmas during holidays
like during every day all the time
so there's they just happy have like a
pretty complex operational process but
it's nailed down pop to the point where
you know it's automated
it's a machine yeah I love the fact that
somebody was like this is such a big
important deal we're gonna really build
a crane to do it right launch cream and
then I guess last thing on this is I'm
assuming this is
somewhat competitive with the SpaceX's
StarLink and kind of the satellites at
their building any thoughts there or
kind of looked at that at all
I'm not an expert on that specific
program but yeah again there's different
approaches to solving Internet in
different parts of the world satellites
balloons etc I don't know which solution
will end up being the winner but
basically from my perspective getting
more people internet access is a great
thing and so the you know the more
competition into space the better it's
gonna be friend users for sure and I
guess how do you go from working on what
many people I think would consider like
some of the coolest technology products
in the world at at Google to then like
oh this Bitcoin and cryptocurrency thing
like that seems cool what was the first
time you ever came across in any of the
crypto stuff so I mean because I've been
on my radar for a while I didn't some
college projects around Bitcoin and
things like that
but the first time I actually seriously
got into crypto at all in any regard was
actually act also at Google in 2014 I
worked on US and launched a small
integration between coinbase and Google
search that would basically send you
these Google now cards every time you
had a transaction like a receive or a
send or a trade things like that so I
had a coin base account I did the team
actually gave me a super small amount of
Bitcoin at the end of that integration
and I didn't really think much about it
for a couple years and then in 2017 I
went back to that and I was like oh my
god holy [ __ ] like this microscopic
amount of Bitcoin like has you know gone
up by over an order of magnitude like
maybe I should pay more attention to
this thing so that got me more
interested in in crypto and I was
largely already quite interested in
finding and finance I felt like it I'm
sure you talked about this before with
your audience and I've seen a lot of
other people mentioned this but the
internet had totally transformed massive
multi-billion dollar industries it
seemed that at Google certainly in
advertising and it was starting to
happen in retail with Amazon and
transportation Luber and left it just it
didn't seem like that same impact had
taken over finance yet a lot of the
financial tools I was used to using were
the same tools that I had always used
and the same tools that even my parents
were used to using and
sure might you know my bank account now
had a mobile app cool but it was the
same Bank running the same currency
doing the same processes running the
same ACH system so I was kind of excited
about FinTech generally and it was
actually going through the process of
trying to start a fin tech startup that
had absolutely nothing to do with crypto
that made me sort of fully realize some
of the pain points of building on
traditional financial rails like ACH
transfers and at that point I was like
okay I have the script of thing I had
started kind of exploring the crypto
space more I think by the summer of 2017
I had like 15 different wallets and like
you know all these different currencies
all these urban exchange accounts and I
was sort of already going down the Kripa
trap clip the rabbit hole and at the
same time I was super frustrated with
the fintechs
tools that we were building for
traditional finance and so those kind of
push and the pull totally sucked me down
a crypto rabbit hole got in and I guess
what was the original genesis for coin
tracker itself was there like one
specific problem or did you kind of have
this vision of let me go build an entire
suite of products for this you know kind
of niche of Finance no it was actually
not meant to be a company at all it was
kind of a personal pain point of my
co-founder John and myself we basically
had these crypto portfolios we had all
these exchanges all these wallets it was
a big mess we started by just creating a
spreadsheet like you know everyone does
you know I'm gonna copy and paste you
know one type you know one key at a time
here's the Bitcoin I bought on this
state at this time with this basis for
this amount and eventually you're
transferring it to a cold wallet and
then you're trying to keep track of that
and then you have Google Apps scripts
running and next thing you know you've
built a database in your spreadsheet and
it takes two minutes to load so it was
kind of the process of just keeping
track of our own cryptocurrency that we
realized damn we need a better solution
for this and so that was kind of the
initial genesis of the idea for coin
tracker it turns out other people had
the same point point yeah and so what
didn't you guys built today and kind of
how does it work in terms of your
relationship with customers so corn
tracker today basically has two major
functions one is a crypto currency tax
software solution and the other is a
portfolio assistant
so the portfolio assistant basically
allows you to in real time track
everything that's happening in your
crypto ecosystem and that could be
trades it could be purchases by cell can
be defy interactions loan interest could
be margin trading you can see basically
everything that's going on in your pepto
ecosystem in one place with automatic
integrations with coinbase and by Nance
compound all the top different crypto
exchanges and platforms the second
product tax service basically reconciles
a unified ledger of all your
transactions and gives you your tax
reports and that works in the UK Canada
Australia etc with the local tax rules
based on that jurisdiction it helps you
become tax compliant got it
and I guess as part of this like there's
the keeping track of everything and then
there's a lot of people out there who
that is a huge problem for them but the
second problem then becomes like okay
what do I do right like I have all this
stuff and all these different exchanges
do I buy some do I sell some did there's
certain times of the year should I sell
right before the end of the year you
know how do I harvest lost like all of
these very complex things that in
traditional finance either there's
financial advisors that are helping
people do it or they're professional
traders right they they actually are
spending all day long thinking about
this in crypto that doesn't seem to be
the case and in many cases how do you
guys you know one thing through that and
to try to help solve that problem yeah
the good news is you know we don't have
to reinvent the wheel there's lots of
very intelligent people who have been
thinking about this outside of crypto
excuse me for regular finances for a
long time and many of those things and
those strategies and tools can be built
for the crypto ecosystem and that's a
lot of what we're doing there are
certainly lots of new sort of nuances
and idiosyncrasies about crypto currency
specifically and that is what makes it
challenging to build a tool in this
space but also what makes it really
valuable so I'll give you some concrete
examples you mentioned like figuring out
what x of years you might want to make
transactions and using strategies to
basically optimize your portfolio so one
thing that coin tracker offers that can
help people save a lot of money I've
used this myself to help save tens
dollars in capital losses is basically
using tax loss harvesting and for
listeners who might not be familiar with
that basically before I go into this
just take the buses informational only
it's not meant as tax advice but there's
a basically a tax rule that will allow
you to sell a cryptocurrency asset that
you have at an unrealized loss and then
buy it back so the effect of that is you
maintain the exact same cryptocurrency
positions as you have before but your
tax bill is lower because you've
internalized and realized a loss that
happened so just to make that even more
concrete let's say you bought Bitcoin at
$10,000 a coin prices dropped to 7k you
can sell the Bitcoin for 7k realize a
$3,000 capital loss and buy back the
Bitcoin you have the same one Bitcoin
you have a $3,000 loss and you can use
that to offset other capital gains or if
you have net losses even ordinary income
and then therefore pay less taxes at the
end of the year yeah and I guess as part
of this there's the tax harvesting and I
think it's important for a lot of people
to understand that this is actually
different than the traditional when I
talk to a lot of traditional investors
they basically say oh there's something
called wash trading or kind of the loss
at the end of the year you can't have a
loss on unrealized an Amazon stock let's
say for the year December 30th sell the
stock and then just buy it back January
first or second right that that wouldn't
count as sexual tax harvest of the
losses here in crypto that's different
maybe kind of explain like why that is
yes and this is the kicker this is why
it's super interesting in crypto
specifically so as you mentioned
normally there's wash sale rules that
make it so that basically the IRS says
your loss is disallowed if you buy back
the same asset 30 days before or after
the disposal so with the let's say the
Amazon stock
example if you were just selling the
Amazon stock at a loss and then buying
it back right away
you wouldn't be able to claim that loss
and the idea there is you know you don't
want people basically taking advantage
of this tax loophole what normal and
financial advisers would do in this
scenario to still allow you to do this
is either wait 30 days so you get beyond
that period or find another asset that
is sufficiently similar in terms of your
diversification of your portfolio to
replace that asset with so typically it
would be if you have one ETF on you know
let's say Vanguard that you're then
selling and then buying back a similar
ETF on Schwab instead so that your
overall risk allocation is the same but
you can still take advantage of not
having to get your wash sales disallowed
in crypto the reason why it's different
is because the wash sale rule is
specifically written in the tax code for
securities and because Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies are classified by the
IRS as property they don't fall into the
wash sale rule now there are some
exceptions some people would argue that
certain cryptocurrencies are security
tokens or the SEC might rule that
certain longtail coins are clearly
securities and so for those they may
fall into the wash though a little but
for Bitcoin it's clear Bitcoin is not a
security this would not apply to it if
there's also likely not a security this
would not apply to it stuff like these
head coins you can basically take
advantage of this loophole that doesn't
exist for let's say stocks for example
yeah and how important is it let's say
that I buy you know five Bitcoin but I
buy them all at different price points
over a period of time and at the end of
the year or when I go to sell two of
them currently at a loss but three of
them I am I have a gain do I need to
make sure that I sell the two bitcoins
specifically that have the loss or can I
just sell any to Bitcoin and then
basically say oh no those are the two
where I'm gonna take a loss and the
other three are fine okay like how
important is it to get the exact Bitcoin
you're now getting into advanced but
really really useful topic that people
can use to save a lot of money and
countenance dream basically but you're
touching on is different kinds of cost
basis accounting methods and the IRS
typically requires people to use one of
two different methods one is first-in
first-out meaning the first coin you get
is the first coin you sell so if you
bought five Bitcoin Bitcoin number one
that you got is the Bitcoin number one
that you sell they also have more
advanced method called specific
identification that is also allowed and
in that method it's kind of like what
you suggested you can pick exactly which
Bitcoin you're disposing of as long as
you meet a certain criteria like keeping
detailed records of what date and time
it happened which coin it was which
wallet it was coming from and going to
what the timestamp what the basis was
etcetera and all these are things that
quaint record would help you optimize
and create records for and the
difference between kind of using FIFO
versus doing some kind of optimization
here can be huge in terms of cash flow
and in terms of tax optimizations
because if you bought again one Bitcoin
at a really low price and then got
another one later at a very high price
you definitely are gonna have a massive
tax difference in terms of which one you
dispose or which one you trade for
altcoins
yeah it's really interesting and they
maybe talked a little bit about kind on
the portfolio side of what you guys do
how much of it is what I'll consider
just like understanding what's happening
versus are you guys making any kind of
predictive recommendations or
suggestions or anything okay so that the
the base thing for sure table stakes is
reconciling what has actually happened
already so what are all my positions
what is all my returned which coins am i
holding which wallets are they in and
that is updating on a real-time basis
every single day you'll have it synced
so it's with API connections and Olaf
integrations with thousands of different
crypto currencies and hundreds of
different exchanges and platforms now
where it gets interesting is how can you
actually act on this information to
improve your portfolio or more
proactively become a better trader or
build wealth in a more efficient way so
we already talked about tax loss
harvesting will also send you daily
notifications about
any new transactions that happen in your
account and your daily return so you
might discover that a certain limit
order that you set up has executed or
that you got air-dropped a coin it's
super common for people to like realize
that they've got airdrops that they
didn't know existed and they'll figure
that out with coin tracker some people
have gotten he's transfer alerts and
then realized someone was trying to move
money out of one of their accounts that
they didn't authorize though they didn't
know about so it'll keep you on top of
that for security purposes if you're
about to make a trade let's say and
you're not exactly sure which coin to
sell or when the right time is coin
tracker can help you understand if
you're gonna incur a short-term capital
gain or loss or a long-term capital gain
in a loss meaning whether you've held
the coin for more than a year or a year
or less and again there's big tax
implications for that so it can help you
optimize those things and again you're
making the exact same trade it's the
same exact positions it's just you're
deciding which coin to move so from a
financial perspective you are making the
same ultimate trade but you are
basically saving yourself a tax bill so
there's lots of optimizations there that
the portfolio tracking will help you
with and ultimately the idea here is we
want to make people more financially
educated more savvy about the tax code
about finances about cryptocurrency
another example of this is around
custody where should you actually store
your coins and it's common for beginners
and new folks getting into the space to
use an exchange or a hot wallet that's
custody by a third party but for people
who have been in the space for a long
time you've seen lots of exchange Hawks
lots of problems with not holding your
own keys and therefore not actually
owning your own coins and so we'll have
tools that will show you what percentage
of your portfolio is self custody and
things like that to help you have better
I would call it crypto hygiene yeah it's
really interesting too because I think
part of this is your building feature
parity with traditional financial
products but then there's specific
nuances to crypto as well right so like
the idea of hey you should understand
your balance you should be able to audit
where things are what their value is how
did that change over time like that's
pretty much available and any asset
class
product an airdrop is very specific to
crypto right it's maybe talked about as
you guys were building the product what
some of those technical hurdles word how
you had to kind of build something very
customized to this industry versus other
financial assets or markets yeah that's
that's absolutely right so again like
there's tons we can learn from people
who have built this before there's tons
of products for tracking other kinds of
assets the fun comes in the interesting
nuances of crypto and there are so many
and since so cutting edge and changing
so rapidly there's always a new thing
but you know someone who's more advanced
than me is teaching me about so airdrops
is an obvious one there's Forks that was
a huge thing when Bitcoin cash for it
you know how do you treat this where is
this income coming from how does this
affect the cost basis that is something
that's fairly unique to crypto there's
dividends and stock splits and things
like that but a fork is somewhat unique
in terms of coming from crypto another
example of this is around defy so
there's so many different products now
where you can earn interest you can do
lending you can do derivatives and the
weird thing is those platforms
oftentimes are decentralized in a way
where there's no company that's
providing you financial statements so
you can't just go to some C Corp or LLC
and say where's your 1099 form you have
to actually integrate with the etherion
block chain or some smart contract and
actually understand what are the
financial mechanics here and then map
that into something that's kind of human
understandable so that's another example
I'm trying to think of some other fun
interesting things that have happened
recently so yeah I think some of the
like futures contracts and derivatives
like ambit max and debit are quite
interesting because they're settled
sometimes in USD or some kind of fiat
currency but sometimes they're settled
in that commodity or that coin itself
and then you're basically incurring
capital gains not only from the
transaction but from the fees that are
being paid in that coin itself so
traditionally with margin trading you
would be you know you'd be speculating
on some kind of financial derivative but
typically the fees are paid in u.s.
dollars but in some of these margin
accounts you're paying fees in crypto
so it's not only the regular transaction
but the fees themselves that are
incurring capital gain so there's all
these kind of weird nuances that we have
to integrate with and keep track of yeah
it's super fascinating what's the is
there anything that you guys kind of
looked at and said hey we don't wanna
try to service or just something that
had no regulatory clarity or any
challenge that you just say look it's
just not worth going there yeah so
unfortunately a lot of things here don't
have regulatory clarity so we don't have
the luxury of just turning things that
are in a gray area down when that does
happen which it happens often we try to
basically make it clear you know here
are the different positions here's a
conservative opinion here's a liberal
opinion you know here's the default
approach we take but you have ultimate
user control on whether or not there are
an infinite number of complexities
though in terms of new platforms that
people want us to support or new defy
protocols or some kind of new
cutting-edge thing that is pretty niche
and so we're not going to support
everything but I think ideally we want
to support every kind of interaction
transaction type platform user flow that
is popular and so we've kind of
prioritize things based on user can that
way actually since you asked the
question let me think so one example of
something that recently came up that was
quite interesting was we had a user who
was living as they were living near the
us-mexico border and they were basically
crossing the border every day and using
crypto for arbitrage between US dollars
and pesos based on some exchanges or
some exchange point right on the US
border and right on the Mexico side of
the border and they sent us a screenshot
where they just had stacks and stacks of
receipts in an entire room full of
receipts that they were manually typing
in one at a time on spreadsheet after
spreadsheet just hundreds of hours so
there's just some like any cases like
that which are tougher for us to support
until it becomes more popular I don't
know how many people are gonna go back
and forth on the border to arbitrage but
that's a pretty damn cool story yeah and
then let's talk a little bit about
speaking of regulation the traditional
financial world
you guys have applied for the payroll
protection program act or loan there may
be talked a little bit about that
process and kind of how it went and I'm
assuming there was a lot of bashing up
your head against the wall and it wasn't
as fun as you know people wanted to
think but they just talked about that a
little yeah so when applications turns
out are never fun so on the one hand I
want to say I'm quite grateful that the
government is doing something I think
Congress has probably done more in the
last couple weeks then it is done in the
last several months or years before that
so I think it's good that they're trying
to do something that's a the execution
of the actual loan application process
was less than smooth so for those who
don't know there's this payroll
protection program from the SBA
government you can see around basically
the goal is to try to help ensure that
small businesses have funds that they
need to maintain payroll for their
employees and there's a bunch of sort of
nuances around what qualifies all
business but kind of at a high level
it's companies that are less than 500
people and that could be restaurants
construction companies could be a
variety of different types of businesses
and there was three hundred fifty
billion dollars allocated for this
payroll protection program the reason
why it was a bit of chaos is because the
actual loans come through banks that you
work with not the SBA themselves which
means you basically go to your bank and
you say hey I would like a loan and they
basically have a unique loan application
process from each bank we work with
first Republic and they actually ended
up doing a relatively great job they
were working around the clock I think it
took 18 days from our initial
application to getting funded we heard
some horror stories from some other
banks where they were prioritizing large
clients or they were prioritizing
clients who already had pre-existing
loans with them or they were
prioritizing or there's dropping loan
applications in the floor entirely and
that is a huge disaster when you have a
huge cash flow problem for example this
year the tax season which is one of our
primary drivers of revenue moved from
April 15 to July to 15th for most
Americans and the implication of that is
revenue that we expect in April is now a
little bit late and that definitely has
big consequences for our business a lot
of restaurants are really struggling
right now they often they're totally
closed or maybe they can only take a few
takeout orders and so for these people
waiting 18 days may not be an option at
all and then we're kind of fortunate a
lot of these people like are in really
desperate situations so to kind of
explain how the process worked basically
April throat third twenty twenty rolled
around that was the day that this
process was supposed to start every bank
was kind of running their own process so
I think Bank of America for example
launched their applications early that
day we use First Republic they launched
that afternoon about evening some of
them had no loan application process set
up at all that day everyone's kind of
frantically watching webinars from every
VC every Twitter person you know every
legal firm is running their own webinar
every HR provider and payroll provider
Augusto pilot rippling etc everyone had
all these webinars everyone is kind of
trying to understand the rules and then
on top of that the rules are changing
every day so each day every night you
would see on CNBC you would see from
like what's going on Twitter you'd see
from Congress House Senate they've
published either more clarification or
more guidance or more nuances or
exceptions as to who's allowed to apply
or what the forgiveness policies are or
what documents are even required and so
it's just total chaos and what ends up
happening is we ended up applying that
same day I think it was around two and a
half hours between when the loan
application open and when we submitted
our materials but then there's a bunch
of back-and-forth because you basically
have to provide a ton of documentation
showing how many employees you had what
the average payroll was over the past 12
months have the records on how you
computed that and then there's a bunch
of calculations that go into it for
example you can't include foreign
employees but you had non us-based
employees you can't include contractors
you can't include salaries above
$100,000 there's all these different
kinds of rules you have to apply and
it's not like we have this complicated
calculation sitting around in some
software it's like the calculations
changing
every single day so we were basically
frantically trying to compute that
luckily some people like Pilate rippling
and others made tools to help automate
these calculations but then it was back
and forth with a loan officer to explain
why we needed a loan how much loan we
needed for how the process would work
what kind of proofs we had that you know
that documented that we actually had a
financial need because of copán related
reasons things like that and so that
process took 18 days eventually we did
get the funding and I'm super grateful
to first Republican again to SBA for
making this possible but it was it was a
bit of a process and I think again we
were one of the lucky ones that we were
able to go through this I think a lot of
people are in a much worse boat yeah it
feels a lot like the government said we
know we're not set up to do this right
and so rather than us try to hand the
money out like what's the next best
thing well let's go through these
traditional channels thanks for used to
giving loans they have customers they
have underwritten some of these people
and they can kind of help us facilitate
that but people forget that the banks
are basically told okay you guys are
gonna do this like 48 hours before it
turned on and then I remember a number
of banks they even like JP Morgan Chase
and some of these the night before we're
like we don't even know what the rules
like we can't take loan application all
morning and so it's you know I think it
was very kind of hard on the applicants
but also I try to be understanding and
say you know for the the banks and those
processing the loans like they were
putting a pretty bad position as well
and given those stamped those situations
for the most part they've done a pretty
good job
you know maybe prioritizing the bigger
customers or giving loans to public
companies and that type of stuff is a
little bit more hard to get mo pass on
but it feels like your experience is
somewhat similar in that it wasn't easy
but you know that they're doing their
best
yeah that's largely right there's
definitely a large variance in what the
best is from one bank to the next but I
think that's right I think it was a
tough position and I do applaud the
government for trying to push these
through quickly like I think they could
have spent months trying to like iron
out all the rules and make sure all the
i's and tees
you know perfect but I think people are
trying their best and and that's a good
thing I think there's also another round
of funding that should I think it passed
the Senate yesterday probably going to
the house later today for additional
funding since the first 350 billion ran
out so quickly
but there's also like adverse effects of
doing all of this like I've heard
stories anecdotally from people where
because of these PPP loans you know it's
hard to get people to actually hire or
get hired for other jobs because people
want to maintain them on payroll even if
they're not doing anything productive
for society again which makes sense like
of course people can't eat people can't
buy stuff so I mean there's nothing
wrong with that but the adverse impact
of that is it might end up making it
harder for the economy to restart in
some cases in some segments when people
are trying to hire people for for new
types of jobs there's just a lot of
weird things and one other sort of last
thought about this is it's it just
occurred to me it's kind of funny that
the government has such a great
infrastructure set up for collecting
taxes from all of us but there isn't a
great sort of system sent for remitting
any sort of stimulus payments or the you
know the yanking bucks or whatever back
to people universally and I think we're
seeing like there's clearly a need like
this this is happening kind of at this
scale for the first time at least in
modern history but doesn't mean it's
give me the last time we probably need
better financial infrastructure it
probably doesn't make sense for banks to
be earning 10 billion in fees for these
loans that they're giving out with zero
to low risk so there's something to be
said for improving the financial system
generally which obviously appeals to me
as someone working in the purpose base
yeah so somebody said to me the
government's really good at collecting
the money they're not so good at handing
it back and you know the part to me that
also is really interesting is the first
350 billion it's like three or four
percent of the applications actually got
processed and the money ended up being
successfully doled out and so like
another 310 billion I think is what is
in this latest bill it's like are they
even get to 10% of the applications like
it just seems like such a small number
compared to what they I saw over a
trillion dollars in loan applications
right and it's just maybe not all of
them are eligible or whatever but just
such big numbers coming out of these
programs that it makes you think do the
politicians Federal Reserve excite
really understand how much economic
carnage there is kind of on the ground
or in reality yeah I totally agree that
I think it's being underestimated by a
lot of folks yeah an additional three
ten billion is it's great it's a good
start but that's definitely not going to
be enough for for everyone and you know
it's muddy printer Coburn like what are
the other solutions here I don't know
I'm not a government expert here but I
don't think it's gonna be enough named
economic carnage it's gonna last longer
and be at a larger scale then I think a
lot of people think yeah that meme is
amazing the whole idea of money printer
Gober I just when I first saw that I was
like that might be one of the best
themes that comes out of all of this and
you can just see it sticking around for
years and years to come
yeah I think I just saw someone tweet
out the the feds or the government's
balance sheet and I mean it's it's
hockey stick growth let's say oh it's
vertical the the the Fed's balance sheet
is legitimately vertical I when I first
saw it there's a quote from Top Gun
where Tom Cruise says he'd like
something like he's going vertical and
so am i right but but it does bring into
the question right it's like it kind of
shows the value of obviously bitcoin
when it comes to money printing and
bitcoin not being able to be manipulated
or the money supply changing but also I
think it changes kind of people's view
of right now everyone here in the United
States were in a dollar denominated
economy right and you start to look
around the world and yes there's central
bank's everywhere injecting liquidity
but there's also other currency
denominated economies right and so you
may get different performance but it's
all the same economic realities
everyone's kind of being ground to a
halt and so it enters the question like
should we have one global currency
should everything be priced in the same
reserve currency like these are all like
big essential questions that previously
kind
got you know brushed aside because it
was just like well what would that
currency be I think now when you see
something like a Bitcoin with a
separation of state money now it's a
little bit more realistic to have that
conversation and you know it's not gonna
get solved tomorrow but it is
interesting to see kind of the economic
situation we're in drive more people to
at least learn about Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and some of the stuff
that you know you I and others have been
working on for a while I totally agree
with that I think there's a lot of these
things that people have taken for
granted because it's just the way things
have been business as usual and now
people are sort of second
second-guessing and questioning
everything you know yesterday we had a
dinner discussion about how negative
with the price of oil have to go for us
to just rent an 18-wheeler and drive to
Cushing and like pick up our barrels of
oil and you know it's kind of like wait
why are we like let's just question all
of our assumptions why is money the way
it is why don't we have a global
currency like we don't have a currency
for every state why do we have a
currency for every country does it make
sense are there better ways doing things
I think kind of getting everyone to
realize these questions and ask these
questions is a is a hugely positive
thing because you know even if nothing
changes at least people are gonna be
understanding how the system works and
what the pros and cons which I think
it's very positive so I gotta ask what
was the consensus on what would the
price of negative oil be so ok I live
with a consultant who is quite good at X
bein guy but I think what we calculated
was we would need to get 218 wheelers of
trucks in order for this to be
economically feasible at a price of
about negative three thousand dollars so
we probably aren't gonna be doing this
anytime soon I'm guessing there will be
some arbitrage before that happens but
if it does get to that you will see me
in Oklahoma look it's pretty crazy
because in that regard so we saw what I
think negative 50 was the low or
somewhere around negative 50 and people
now for the may futures physically
settled contract maybe one in June right
now is still trading positively but I
was starting to do some calculations on
how much storage is available in the US
how much oil is already on its way to
the United States and there's some
estimations that it could be like you
know 50 million barrels that are already
on boats on the way here and then you
start to look at it you're like okay so
we've got you know maybe a month or so
before people are going to panic again
or what is demand gonna increase that
materially to get oil out of storage
probably not and so like are we gonna
see what just happened this month next
month but on a bigger scale and like my
whole thing was like could we see
negative triple digits but could we see
negative 100 or worse and I like yeah
like it's possible right I mean it's not
gonna stay there probably but like we
could see that and I think that it's one
of these things throughout this entire
economic shock where every time you
think it's as bad as it's gonna get it
gets worse
right unemployment number there's like
all these things it's just kind of
scared yeah I think the negative hundred
dollar barrel oil would have like people
would have laughed in your face a couple
weeks ago if you were to suggest that
and now it's like wow that mean anything
is possible where we're gonna put all
this oil and unemployment numbers are
staggering I think that it's over 20
million now
so yeah it's totally crazy I think
unemployment NSF has San Francisco has
gone from 2% to probably over 20% in the
last month again unfathomable a couple
months ago so people are really
questioning everything it's super scary
I think it's gonna last longer than
people think so I'm hoping people are
staying home staying safe but we also
need to figure out a plan for the
economic side of things like this isn't
feasible for a lot of people for a long
time yeah and then I guess last question
for you here before gated rapid-fire is
just like how has Kovac changed your
guys plan so obviously there's the
impact on revenue right you had to deal
with all the PPP stuff but in terms of
either product development cycles or
hiring plans all that like what's
changed due to this virus other that you
got a sit and sit at home and wear masks
meet you outside I personally love
working from home so I think I'm Way
more open to remote only work so that's
one change but I think the biggest
change for the
vini as a whole has been a lot more
focus on rapid product development and
especially trying out ideas that were a
little bit more out there and just being
like you know what the hell what's the
worse that can happen like it's go big
or go home type of thing right now so
launching more stuff bigger stuff faster
and more quickly and being more willing
to experiment which I actually think
ultimately is a good thing for us so
that's been the biggest change for us
from coming yeah makes sense rapid-fire
before we finish up you could ask me one
question what is your most controversial
thought in all of crypto o most
controversial thought in all of crypto
hmm I used to be into lots of different
tokens and coins but I've become more of
a Bitcoin maximalist recently so I I
think most coins most tokens are totally
worthless maybe an exception for stable
coins and a few D 5 things other than
Bitcoin I don't know there's probably
some people who agree with me there but
I think that's my that's one of my
thoughts welcome to the light what uh
what's the one rule or regulation you
would change if you could encrypt or
just in general it will do in general in
general I definitely have a little bit
of libertarian bent to me so I don't
like generally the government teller to
do they make me read there's some
exceptions there hmm let me think about
that one I think there's an obvious
example for crypto specifically and
since we work on taxes I think one thing
that's kind of holding the industry back
a bit is basically having capital gains
on every little transaction I think if
there were a de minimis exception
basically not taxing small transactions
and stable coin transactions and things
like that that would be better for the
industry as a whole that's very neat for
this I'd have to think a little bit more
on if I could change any law I would
be--that's yeah so much free rein there
what would you make the de minimis
exemption be like what would that dollar
Malby
well I they hide 600 dollars and that
failed because people thought it was too
high so I think getting it to any level
where people would be willing to pass it
practically would be good to under
dollars would be a good start I think
there's some some folks in Congress we
spoke to who are trying to do that
two dogs would be a good start at least
got it make sense most important book
you've ever read lots of good ones I'm
currently reading the Black Swan by
Nassim Taleb which is relevant let's go
although I think according to him this
is not actually a Black Swan maybe the
price of oil make it at this Black Swan
but that is interesting I really like
Guns Germs and Steel
I read that back in the day I think
that's a sort of an interesting
explanation of just the state of the
world that's one of my favorite books it
was a Jared Diamond alright the last
question before you get ask me one
aliens believer non-believer I think
unquestionably they must exist it's lies
there's there's just so much of that
vast universe out there I think it's
there it's like it reminds me of when
humans used to think the earth was the
center of the universe it's like why do
we think we're the only planet that has
life it seems so self-centered
it just it's unfathomable to me that
there isn't life on other planets
there's so many planets do you think we
understand space or the ocean more oh
the oceans I think are not well
understood but space I think is so much
more vast there's so much we don't know
it's so much bigger that I would I would
go with space alright that's fine
what a one question yeah with for me to
finish up okay so I did a little bit of
snooping on your background what is the
most interesting thing you learned as a
sergeant in the army and what is the
least useful thing you learned at
Facebook that you had to unlearn by far
the most useful thing as a sergeant in
the army is to never ask someone to do
something you're unwilling to do
yourself and I think that is the Army
does a really good job so first I don't
know you have to go to a number of
schools or one school I forget to
basically become a sergeant there's a
specific leadership school you go to and
all this stuff
and there's ways that this manifests
itself in
some big ways in some small ways so a
big way would be if a bunch of things
need to be physically moved somewhere
and I am your sergeant like I shouldn't
ask you to do it unless I'm willing to
go do it right and so that's like a
pretty cut-and-dry example and you just
want your soldiers to know hey like he
has my back right he's a good leader
he's willing to come out here and do it
with us it's not you work for me go do
it cuz I said so type stuff so so I
think a lot of people in the military
their view of the military's it's very
hierarchical and obviously there is
ranks and there is that to some degree
but at the same time like these people
are going to listen to you if you
inspire them if you kind of show them
why they should follow you and so I
think that's one piece of it and then
the other thing is like stupid [ __ ] like
when you go to eat one of the big things
is in the military you'll find a lot of
times that sergeants will literally
fight with each other
not like fistfight necessarily but just
like argue with each other as to who
gets to be in the back of the line and
it's because they want all the soldiers
to eat first
right and then the sergeants will eat or
the officers will eat and so you kind of
build into the culture this idea of the
people who are in charge at the various
levels they take care of the men and
women who they are in charge up right
and that goes to them eating first and
all that kind of stuff and so when you
compare that to other parts of society
that's a little bit different like a lot
of people say oh I'm in charge I go
first and so getting that I think was a
it was cool to kind of get both the
leadership lessons in the academic
portion of it but then also you kind of
put it in practice and see how how
beneficial it is and then in terms of
face book so I was there at the time
context I think really matters I was
there in 2014-2015 and I would say that
the two things actually there's one
thing so there's a blessing and a curse
Facebook is the best in the world in my
opinion obviously high bias at using
data to solve problems and I was on
ran in a roar of different growth teams
and product teams and saw that in action
over and over and over again where most
people would walk into a room and say
well I think that X is true or Y is true
Facebook was very good because they have
so much traffic at designing these tests
running multivariate tests and getting
the data to tell you the answer and then
kind of pushing through whether it was
growth plateaus or design problems and
things like that and so obviously you
train yourself and your colleagues every
time that we have a problem let's just
run a test and the data will tell us the
answer that works really really well
like 80 90 percent of the time there are
cases though where like that's not the
right approach and so we became so good
at it that in hindsight you know there's
certain times both that Facebook and
afterwards where you look at a problem
say the data can inform my
decision-making but I shouldn't just
like whatever the data tells me go do it
and so I think that it's a thing where
because it was so effective it also led
then to at least you know my team being
a little blind of just like let's go
follow the data and so luckily we
weren't working on anything weird like
that could have really adverse effects
to to users but you could easily see you
know when you get into the conversation
on fake news on all the different
platforms and things like that well if
you're just optimizing for clicks then
actually some of the more salacious less
credible content may drive more clicks
and you know how do you balance that
stuff and so I think that you know
that's not a problem just at Facebook
it's kind of around the the social media
or technology companies but that's
probably the answer there that's super
cool I like both of us yeah well where
can people go go find more about a coin
tracker and you as well yeah for sure
Quinn tracker is coin tracker CEO int R
a cker dot IO you can check us out on
our website we're also at coin tracker
on twitter and you can follow me on
twitter as well at CG low-tom ello DHA
how did you get that calling tracker
nobody had that on Twitter that's
actually another fun story we actually
had another user name and we closely
been monitoring this for a long time the
account was quite
active and we followed some steps
contacted Twitter said the account was
not being used could we have the handle
and they gave it to us ah I see you guys
went the the the path of Twitter I know
a lot of people who slide in the DMS and
it becomes a negotiation from you know
hundred dollars of 500 I've heard people
selling so these accounts for for
thousands of dollars going the Twitter
account is much cheaper
yeah it was a nice price of zero awesome
Manuel listen I really appreciate them
time to do this I hope people go check
out coin tracker both for the portfolio
management and also for a lot of the tax
services that you guys offer and that
what do this again as hopefully the
crypto market comes raging back from
from this nice little winter we've had
thanks so much pumpin someday you might
find ourselves driving to Oklahoma
together to get some oil love it